[Musique]
united 367 prêt pour le décollage
attendant l'instruction est ainsi 367
traiteur intense
des décennies de phénomènes aériennes
ont expliqué entouré de mystère jusqu'à
maintenant c'est quoi ce ton job
[Musique]
vous êtes l'un des plus talentueux
étudiants que je connaisse et vous allez
chou et à mon cours vous êtes ou quoi
cet après midi tous les vols à
l'aéroport de cincinnati ont été
temporairement annulée suite au survol
du site par un mystérieux appareil il me
faudra aussi les images prises sur
l'ensemble du site
je veux tous ses passagers en salle de
réunion par pensons qu'il s'agissait
d'un petit drone jamais c'est bien plus
grand
quand j'étais gosse j'ai vu quelque
chose ces lumières peur c'était par
aaron le cas à la télé il a menti
vous n'allez pas automatiquement vous en
remettre à l'explication la plus
fantaisiste qui existe il s'agit pas
d'un vulgaire problème de maths c'est
plus compliqué que tout ce que vous avez
pu voir jusqu'ici la salle
d'embarquement et bourré à craquer
d'agents fédéraux
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont là
puisqu'ils ont soit disant trouver ce
que c'était je vous demande de lui dire
de ceux ci
le fbi a pris la main sur nos
ordinateurs
pourquoi j'ai pas vu ça avant tu crois
que c'est une sorte de signer ça c'est
du binaire il utilise des maths de base
pour communiquer si j'ai raison ils
reviendront alex charme et la pernelle
kilian anderson david strathairn
on a une formidable occasion de faire un
véritable pas jay o
tout repose là-dessus quelles sont les
questions les plus importantes qu'on se
pose tous
est-ce que tu existes
après la mort il se passe quoi
est-ce qu on est seuls dans l'univers
si quelqu'un répond dès lors une seule
de ces questions ça bouleverserait
compliments l'échauffement
ovni sur la piste des extraterrestres
dix mois madame hendrix pourquoi je n'ai
pas eu de points pour l'exercice numéro
vous n'avez pas répondu
vous avez oublié une solution trivial x
et gaz et vaud et y égal zéro je ne vais
pas obligé j'ai jugé que ce n'était pas
important trouver toutes les solutions
vous connaissez le sens du mot tout
monsieur etc et varrault